after more than 35 years China is ending
its one-child policy now families will
be able to have two children but no more
why because the population is aging and
its workforce is shrinking
that's an imbalance that will hurt
China's economy for years to come to
curb a population that was spiraling out
of control China's government embarked
on its radical policy of one child per
family in 1978 while China still has the
world's biggest population of 1.3
billion the policy is estimated to have
prevented 400 million in additional
birds well the regulations did much more
than just reduce China's numbers the
government cracked down on people who
had more than one child with fines
forced abortions and even sterilization
it also had huge effects on the
country's culture it's not just forced
abortions it's not just sterilization
it's make questions like well Who am I
gonna marry who could I date okay what
kind of home can I afford to buy and how
am I gonna age gracefully
traditionally boys were favored over
girls in China as it was believed only a
son could continue a family's legacy and
in rural areas boys were viewed as
better laborers so some families gave
their girls up for international
adoption while others took more drastic
measures like infanticide the population
is so lopsided for example that in terms
of dating I mean you have 30 million
more men than women and you also have a
large population of only child singleton
so parents are very invested in the kind
of their children's dating choices now
the government needs people to have more
babies and have them fast but it might
not happen as quickly as hoped two years
ago the government started relaxing the
rules allowing couples a second child if
one of the parents was himself a single
child but many couples who qualified
didn't even take advantage of it the
financial burdens that young Chinese
families face makes having a second
child a difficult choice especially if
they have two sets of parents to take
care of - and at this point a one-child
family has become the cultural ideal
this mindset has become so ingrained I
mean I have plenty of friends who would
not even have consider having a second
child
we call that Tyrell thank you
a chihuahua they are you ever hang up la
la la yeah yeah sure 2news Yamaha so it
seems China is in a bind
after decades of telling families to do
things one way it wants them to suddenly
start doing it another until schooling
housing and health care start becoming
more affordable
many families might stick with the
one-child policy long after it's gone